Melissa Wade dick is 17 years old the
South African girl is committed to
combating violence in the community of
nelson mandela bay once a week the
schoolgirl visits the grave of her
friend Cindy brutally raped and murdered
two years ago filling off mixed emotions
because now it's my first time here
after the burial I was last year at the
Bernadette burial beg vanua stones in
shock because we didn't expect it I
think now it is sang in that we may
never see Sydney again maybe we'll see
her in the afterlife san Alyssa way dick
lives in warmer Township a poor
neighborhood with high levels of
unemployment and violent crime often
young people are not only the victims
but also the perpetrators of violence
because must have been working gang so
yeah if you want to fit in you go into
the skang and then you do also stations
all sorts of wrong stuff because you
just want to fit in yeah and then of
course unemployment also has a major
role to play and poverty but I think the
main reason is his parent Asia and
poverty together with some friends son
Alyssa way started the project youth for
safer communities to make young people
think about their role in the creation
of safer spaces the NGO masa funda
trains them how to best promote their
topic the three friends have now been
selected to present their safety
proposals to the mayor of the city
respectful reason there's a reason why
does a janela abundant assuming this
honor we have faith in you we know that
you guys can viewers we're tired of
playing the victims it's time that we
took charge of our lives and what is
happening around us so I want to show
them that weekend we are part of the
problem so we can't be part of the
solution
cinelli so a dick wants young people to
take responsibility and to take action
for a healthy environment such as
renovating a rundown classroom the big
day has arrived to present their
proposals for a safer City to the mayor
now the first issue was that everyone
not everyone contributes in the creation
of safer spaces people feel that it's
the job of the government or the police
whereas it's a shared responsibility you
already know the detail of the whole
path so well done I'm very encouraged
both by their own stories of what they
want to pursue in future as well as the
kind of society and communities that
they want to see in the metro together
with her friends and masa funda she will
make sure that young people will have
their say about the future of nelson
mandela bay